hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be a prophecy video all about Ozora
hi using some new context from the TV
show and some stuff from the books so
just careful for spoilers for everything
through season 6 so far the writers the
producers have had a little fun messing
with us this season the show had a
little bit of fun this year making you
think that Jon Snow and tenaris are both
the people who were promised the High
Priestess a marine called Daenerys the
one who was promised Melisandre called
Jon Snow the one who was promised
she's also used the term missoura High
but she hasn't used that term since she
resurrected Jon Snow and called him the
prince who was promised so the first
time we actually hear the prophecy
spoken aloud it's by Melisandre Xena
Davos chapter from a Clash of Kings so
she says there will come a day after a
long summer when the stars bleed in the
cold breath of Darkness falls heavy on
the world in this dread hour a warrior
shall draw from the fire a burning sword
and that sword shall be Lightbringer the
red sword of heroes and he who clasps it
shall be Azure 'hi come again in the
darkness shall flee before him so
immediately you're thinking about
Stannis pulling what he called
Lightbringer out of the snow that was
kind of the moment Davos was like oh my
god this is terrible what have I gotten
myself into I've got to get rid of this
red witch so the idea of azure high and
the prince was promised go hand in hand
but because it's a Valyrian prophecy its
gender-neutral so it should be the one
who was promised meaning that it could
be a female it could be a male but the
show was actually pretty honest about
the way it trolls you with Melisandre as
visions like I was wrong I
misinterpreted the vision that Stannis
was the one who has promised clearly Jon
Snow is the one who has promised but
then in another story like in Daenerys
his storyline the red priestess comes up
to High Priestess who would arguably be
more important than Melisandre is like
Daenerys is the one who was promised so
the show is giving you a little
historical context on the idea of the
long night how that ended with the Zora
High Azure High come again as in the
long night is coming again like the war
for the dawn there'll be another
mythical hero to rise and beat the
darkness back if you've been watching
the way the show gives you clues like
the Jon Snow reveal or the idea that
visions can be interpreted in wrong way
you come to the conclusion that there is
not going to be one mythical figure
there will be two mythical figures so it
will be a Song of Ice and Fire
it sounds really simple when you boil it
down to that like Jon Snow very clearly
going to be this amazing leader that we
want Cersei is going to be the other
side of that coin that's really terrible
clean that people want to get rid of
Daenerys even though she has a little
bit of the Mad King inside her also
fairly benevolent so if Jon Snow is the
product of a Song of Ice and Fire
then Jon Snow and Daenerys themselves
will probably be the ones who are
promised to beat back the darkness what
about the flaming sword well when you
think about the Dragons and the ideas of
misinterpreting metaphors till you think
they're much more appropriate as a
flaming sword than an actual sword
that's set on fire like a tiny little
sword even if it's Valyrian steel just
seems so mundane compared to actual
dragon flame now I do think the Valyrian
Steel's going to be very important
Samwell stole a Valyrian sword he's in
the Citadel he'll probably find secrets
about how to make more of those that
will involve dragon fire in obsidian so
what's going to be happening next season
is actually you know pretty laid out
initially it's going to be Daenerys
versus Cersei Jon Snow tried to make
ready for the White Walkers hopefully
with the help of brand the new
three-eyed Raven so think about the big
season six revealed Jon Snow's mother
was Lyanna stark the ice part of the
equation even though we all know who his
father is the show hasn't officially
revealed that yet they'll probably do
that next year
so you get the fire part of that
equation season 8 will be the big war
for the dolt like the final coming
together of Jon Snow and Daenerys so
what they'll probably be doing next year
in addition to revealing a little bit
more about Jon Snow's heritage Lyanna
Stark Rhaegar Targaryen is the idea that
neither of the priests on either side of
this equation have interpreted the
prophecy correctly and it's going to be
this coming together of Jon Snow
Daenerys and I think for the most part
people will probably on that it's really
just the particular the people are
curious about the details like can Jon
Snow control dragons he was burned by
fire even even though in the books we
know that Targaryens can be burned by
fire there's just a number of
inconsistencies with the TV show so you
kind of just have to roll with whatever
explanation they give you but when the
TV show reveals things like
Lyanna Stark they do it in very obvious
visual ways so the really important
thing to look out for in season seven
isn't so much them revealing rhaegar
targaryen
its revealing the Ozora hot like the
idea that Jon Snow and Daenerys coming
together is like the true mythical
savior like the partnership that they'll
have to form like you'll have the forces
in the north
anybody that survives in the crown lands
in whatever's left of Daenerys is army
they'll all have to come together in the
heads of the dragon the three heads of
the Dragon will be the mythical savior
so while the show is having a little bit
of fun making you wonder who this
mythical Savior is you know these couple
seasons the twist I think will be is
that there is no one single person who
is the Savior it's two people and their
story will be a Song of Ice and Fire
just like you know Rhaegar Targaryen
Lyanna stark their song as in Jon Snow
is literally a Song of Ice and Fire
so that metaphor of Song of Ice and Fire
will continue to be a big thing they'll
tease that in season seven and then
literally we will probably see that play
out during season eight and just to
clarify the idea of azure high being
born under the bleeding star just
explain what that is so the literal text
is when the red star bleeds in darkness
gathers Azure high shall be born again
amidst smoke and salt to wake dragons
out of stone so at the end of season six
as we're witnessing Jon Snow's birth Ned
Stark lays Arthur Dayne sword dawn which
has a star on the hilt I mean it's
literally made out of a meteor which is
a falling star in it's bleeding so the
red star is bleeding as Jon Snow is born
he's born under the bleeding star and
then back during season one when
Daenerys was lighting Khal Drogo's
funeral pyre the red star like the red
comet was overhead as she was reborn as
the mother of dragons
waking dragons from stone literally like
the stone eggs
so both Jon Snow and Daenerys were born
under a bleeding red star so it's just
more evidence that they are both the one
who was promised and they will come
together and it'll be a Song of Ice and
Fire
but let me know in the comments what is
your interpretation of the idea of azure
hi do you think it's one person do you
think it's multiple people he's supposed
to wield a blazing sword do you think
that'll actually be a physical sword or
do you think the dragons are the flame
sword I just I feel like it works better
as a metaphor like Song of Ice and Fire
flaming swords flying through the sky
they just seem so much cooler in a
better reveal like oh it's not just some
simple piece of flaming metal it's like
a giant dragon flying through the sky
breathing fire but like I said what I'm
expecting is is they'll tease the idea
of multiple ones who were Pramod like
they'll just continue to troll you
through season seven give you some more
information about jon snow's parentage
give you some more evidence that
suggests that Daenerys is the one who is
promised and then in season eight it'll
be like the literal reveal like okay
we're going to have to work together to
defeat the army of the Dead so what's
going to happen is I was originally
going to do a QA but I felt like this is
a little bit more fun and would give us
some more stuff to talk about in the QA
video so leave all your questions about
is or hi or really anything from the
series and I'll just post the Q&A in a
couple days there is a new round of the
giveaway but I'm going to name a winner
because I was originally gonna do a Q&A
now so congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Ren Cruz you in a twenty
dollar Amazon gift card just be sure to
private message be on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details that's just on the about page so
what's gonna happen is is I'll announce
a new winner of the giveaway when I post
the Q&A so all you have to do to enter
the giveaway is just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video and I'll
post the Q&A in a couple days so like I
said next season and when you're
rewatching the old episodes just look
out for pieces of evidence that suggests
that Jon Snow is the one who was
promised in Daenerys was the one who was
promised but like I said being born
under the bleeding star is probably the
strongest piece of evidence the latest
piece of evidence is that Jon Snow is
the child of Ice and Fire so it
continues there'll be a lot more of that
happening during season 7 it's always
fun when you spot Clues like that and
they're usually pretty obvious with it -
like a Targaryen alone in the world is a
terrible thing just as Jon Snow walks in
the room so while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn why Jon Snow might be the true
king of Westeros and you can click here
for all my season 7 predictions thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight